des détritus des halls abîmé cette
situation a poussé marie-christine
motaze à s'engager à d'autres locataires
de livrer à montigny le bretonneux par
rapport aux charges que quand nous
demander et par rapport à l'entretien de
nos bâtiments par rapport aux services
qu'un bailleur nounou doigt parce qu'on
a des on a des devoirs c'est payer notre
loyer mais on a aussi des droits c'est
de vivre dans un lieu propre et se
sentir respecté
j'ai dû constater d'amélioration mais on
voit bien que l'entretien courant n'ai
pas fait ça c'est quand même une
obligation des bailleurs la résidence et
gérés par le bailleur céder ses habitats
une réunion s'est tenue lundi 15 février
la société de nettoyage est
régulièrement mis en demeure
ces derniers mois nous avons remarqué
une multiplication des actes
d'incivilité qui ont participé à
l'insatisfaction de nos locataires à ce
titre en fait nous avons envoyé des
courriers d'avertissement aux locataires
identifier et nous nous sommes
rapprochés des services de la ville et
de la police pour obtenir une patrouille
plus régulière depuis le 4 février cdc
met en place des vacations d'agents de
médiation
onze caméras devraient être installées à
partir de mars 2021 livret est
réhabilité depuis deux ans à plaisir une
habitante du val hibou connaît des
conditions difficiles le 11 janvier
dernier le tribunal de versailles
reconnaît la faute du bailleur les
résidences yvelines essonne quoi qu'elle
fasse en termes de ménage jamais elle ne
parviendra à enlever cette d'heure de
moisi parce que l'isolation des fenêtres
laissent à désirer parce qu'elles
évacuent les eaux usées sont la blanche
dans son évier
j'espère sincèrement que effectivement
cette cette petite décision qui est
toute petite pierre à l'édifice pour la
lutte contre les appartements insalubres
permettront aux gens de se dire que bell
les bailleurs sont pas forcément
intouchable le bailleur prend acte de
cette décision de justice et ne souhaite
pas la commenter
une demande de relogement de la
résidante a été déposé selon la
fondation abbé pierre la france
compterait entre 450 mille six cent
mille logements
venir